c'est qui vient de voir l'artiste
l'animateur comédien le mannequin le
fantaisiste
très bien merci jean luc lemoine jean
luc lemoine fantaisiste vous connaissez
le principe ans norbert oui il voit tout
ce qui se passe vous ai balancé basse à
ces surfaces et sur elle même sur les
invités ben oui oui mais justement c'est
une question ce qui concerne nos invités
non c'est vrai oui je suis bien tombé
allez une question bonjour je m'appelle
monique j'ai été très émue par le
discours de jean luc reichmann dans
votre émission
mais je n'ai absolument rien compris est
ce que vous pourriez m'aider
le look pour une fois je suis choqué par
cette question chez chekhemani kkr site
est pourtant limpide
c'était la reprise ne touche pas on
passe après les sombres événements de
charlie hebdo
jean-luc venait faire la promo de sa
pièce hibernatus et au lieu de s'asseoir
il va s'installer à côté de cyril et
nous expliquer bon je vais très fort
j'ai pas compris
j'avais mais ce qui me rassure quand
même c'est que cyril non plus ma série
non plus et donc on sent qu'il fait
semblant cyril il est perdu vous allez
voir à la fin il fait un petit mouvement
de tête pour faire genre non ça va pas
non il sympa comme tout le monde ça va
pas ça va pas parce que voilà je sais
pas si si je vais arriver à le dire mais
tu vois je viens de passer là et je
viens de voir une dame labaki et en rosé
qui attend un enfant et je me dis moi
qui qui est toujours je me suis toujours
battu bonjour madame bonsoir oui je me
suis toujours battue et pour les pour
les enfants et je me dis sincèrement
nous qui sommes sur scène julien qui
commence demain soir au trévise moi qui
ai commencé ce week-end on se doit nous
faire un petit bilan à mi parcours
brashear il a appris que julien était
sur scène au trévise et que jean luc
était pas bien qu'arrivée une femme
enceinte dans le public grossit et
largué complet mais ça il va faire
semblant de suivre le problème c'est que
ça va continuer et cyril va complètement
décrochés alors j'ai préféré un peu dans
discours parce que j'ai que 15 minutes
de rubriques on se retrouve au moment où
cyril est au bout du rouleau clients et
ça va ça se voit pas du tout nos enfants
n'ont pas n'ont pas voulu être là tu
compenses que je veux dire la base même
et je suis très ému parce que je me bats
et et isabelle morini-bosc m'envoie des
sms en disant c'est bien c'est la
brigade des mineurs
au final pour répondre à monique est ce
que quelqu'un autour de la table nous
résumer la pensée de jean luc reichmann
non jean-michel on essaye tout on pense
que je veux dire la base même et je suis
très ému parce que je me bats et les
événements les événements vide est
arrivé savait pas trop non mais c'est
sûrement ce positionnement est ce que je
viens et je fais de lui puisque la dalle
bien sûr mais c'est vrai que je n'ai pas
mis la main sur l'épaule
je voulais le maire mais c'était trop
gênant à la fin on sait que la mieux
arrête mais c'était un bon moment sinon
on va passer à autre chose
des masques des missions c'est moctar
gardez pas du tout il n'est pas du tout
concerné mokhtar qui je vous le rappelle
est à la fois agent de sécurité
l'animateur intérimaire et sextoys de
cyril hanouna
mais ça va c'est toujours bienveillant
mais rassure toi mon retard tout le
monde te respecte
réponse encore une fois votre héros mais
c'est pas bien c'est de l'amitié
en tout cas d'après jean-michel mais
oktar aime ça je crois qu'il a un
problème moteur
parce que sur le prochain prime sur tout
ça pasqua qui l'a problème enfin c'est
ce que je croyais je croyais qu'il avait
un problème mais en fait pas du tout les
mêmes
jean-michel peut être très tendre
regarder cyril va faire porter une
perruque à son nounours et bah ça va
attendrir jean-michel ouais mais là je
lai on dirait rika zaraï
d'accord
le moteur côté le bâtard ce village sava
motards parler pour jean-michel en fait
le lui en veux pas le mec à la tourette
c'est tout il est juste hargneux par
exemple quand j'ai eu le privilège
d'être invité dans cette émission
bassil avait préparé un petit
questionnaire regardez la dernière fois
que vous avez couché avec une fille elle
vous a dit bravo
ce qu'on ne dit pas c'est à propos de
bertrand chamerois sais c'est que c'est
une petite [ __ ]
justement je voulais faire un spectacle
qui ressemble à ce que je peux être dans
l'émission donc je pense que les gens
qui m'aiment bien les missions sont très
bons on ne peut pas ça comme ça me fait
plaisir parce que moi je me suis fait
massacrer alors qu'il n'avait pas vu le
même toit
il est pas drôle du tout mais quand
j'arriverai fait chaud pourquoi les gens
la police s'est très tôt de nuit est
tombée à la gueule il faut savoir vous
allez partir il m'appartient elle va
s'en prendre plein la tronche mais je
pense qu'ils aient déjà commencé mais
jean-michel il aime deux choses dans la
vie dire des saloperies
et quand même les jolies femmes la
semaine dernière nous recevions la
chanteuse camille loup et jean-michel
était comme un fou mais franchement ça
s'est pas vu
ce
à tuer mais plus vous êtes des filles un
peu mignon mais n'importe quoi elle a
dit c'est millions dans ces pathétiques
c'est mignon c'est la période où j'étais
seul ça ouais ça y est en tout cas là on
le voit il est amoureux mais je vais pas
caricaturer s'exercer c'est pas la
plastique avantageuse de camille loup
qui l'a séduit non ce qu'il a aimé c'est
l'artiste pas contents de la voir
voilà
je vais pas possible jean-michel
respecter les autres affiches on sait
jamais qui avaient fusé avec plusieurs
casquettes je sais pas la petite est
invitée c'est pour nous rappeler ses
autres cascades c'est quoi la crise non
animatrice non plus auteur musicien les
méchants deux chanteuses avoir une belle
casquette google vous savez touche pas à
mon poste c'est avant tout du grand
spectacle se fait appeler grâce à cyril
arena dans l'émission vous le savez
peut-être pas mais elle est reprise dans
le monde entier
par exemple le jour où cyril a décidé de
lancer un petit suisse en l'air pour
atterrir dans sa bouche
eh bien on a battu des records
d'audience aux philippines où cyril est
considéré comme un demi dieu
exceptionnellement nous ils vont placer
une caméra chez les téléspectateurs qui
ont vraiment apprécié ce spectacle
même s'ils ont eu un peu peur pour vous
au début a voulu que ces appareils en
dessous pareil non
et sans rigoler voulais pas le faire si
vous emmerder tout le monde sa rivale
quand vous enlevez le papier du petit
soummam effet pas là et en fait il faut
taper là d'un coup sec
les contrats
même si vous avez voulu faire il faudra
pas plus ferme à ce jour
bien qu'il était attiré par mon oeil
j'ai fait une mine au sous le choc de la
semaine maintenant ce sont des images
dures je vous préviens jean luc
reichmann animer un jeu non mais ça ne
concerne pas isabelle va faire une
blague mais deux possibilités si vous
aimez bien isabelle concentrez-vous sur
la réaction de thierry moreau si vous ne
l'aimez pas regarder plutôt julien
courbet ce moment où même un animateur
aguerris ne peut plus cacher sa
consternation
c'est ce sondage a été effectué sur les
18 69
ouais je ne vais pas tant par les
problèmes de logement on ne dira jamais
aussi
c'est maladroit la tête que je viens
parce que le postulat thuel c'est ma
copine j'ai eu peur pour aller devant la
gêne on n'y va pas il a eu peur mais là
il était au bout du rouleau qui ne l'a
plus arrivé depuis tombé regardez
regardez ce sondage a été effectué sur
les 18 69 ans ouais d'accord je ne vais
pas tant parlé à bâle et bienne le
logement on ne dira jamais ici jean-luc
un soutien trop bavard
aujourd'hui c'est cool avec vous mais
nous on n'a pas peur on vous a lâché
parce que j'ai pas compris la blague 69
ans vit les uns sur les autres la crise
du logement sous sas et j'étais plutôt
rigolo c'est jamais bon quand on
explique une vanne je suis d'accord mais
ça méritait pas ce regard de tueur alors
pour consoler isabelle jours écoulés
coûte cave où il savait isabelle et
c'est souvent de prendre la parole dans
l'émission et c'est pas toujours facile
non
et une foule sur moi je le vois ça
pendant l'émission disons que vous
faites les missions julia pareil et on
la voit que vous à être mais parce que
je suis un match de tennis
voilà quatre ans a dit oui ils ont tous
les ans sauf évidemment à wiltz abb a
très bien alors si je peux quand même
vous demander une faveur il donnait à ce
que vous la parole à isabelle mais on
lui donne pas ce qu'elle dit souvent des
choses intéressantes il ya un seul
problème c'est que c'est dans une langue
étrangère
ah c'est ça regardez voilà donc pour
dire que ça marche bien donc on avait
les mauvaises enfin il est 3ème chaîne
nationale sur la non non non
je suis d'accord c'est vous essayez de
trouver ce qu'a laissé dire j'ai regardé
vous en rappelez ou pas du tout j'ai pas
compris assez énorme
c'est énorme ça jean luc voilà donc pour
dire que ça marche bien donc on avait
des mauvaises sur feu et 3ème chaîne
nationale sur la non non ça donnait il
faut le remettre tous les jours ça je
vous le mettez doba aux dires mêmes
issus de l'étude avouent leur en but est
d'être malheureux mais programme edward
mavericks et bani walid et et que deux
jours assure isabelle n'est pas la seule
à galérer pour prendre la parole
l'autre jour valérie benaïm était
désespérée de pas avoir pu parler
heureusement jean michel être les mots
qui réconfortent
l'émission toi avants palois robert
si tu arrives au début une fois
brioude et c'est déjà pas mal
c'est une rebelle vous allez voir parce
que valérie n'est pas comme ça et se
plaint pas ouais donc en femme
responsable à la préférant parler
directement à cyril passé way qui va pas
l'entendre du tout
moi j'ai pas parlé du tout ce qui tend
son inventaire je voulais que tu vas lui
remettrai ouais c'est inquiétant
vous allez vote du sénat il se passe
tellement 24 heures/24 avec elle on à la
radio ensemble ont déjà ici on est
ensemble ici le soir elle redescend
parking souvent avec moi j'en peux plus
mais naïve voilà bon il se passe rien
dans le parking à ne vous inquiétez pas
mais c'est vrai qu'on est tellement que
comme ça que en fait c'est comme si
voilà j'ai joué mais quoi tout même la
nuit parfois j'ai l'impression d'avoir
fait d'aviva côté voir effet les
commentaires bon vous l'avez plus parler
un peu plus un beau but
bon ça va mieux depuis bah oui super
mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous avez
parlé plus que tout le monde c'est vrai
oui 3 non non non ça va heureusement la
complicité si vous voulez juste jean-luc
je crois que norbert doit partir au
théâtre ah bah c'est comme vous voulez
ouais bien oui c'est vrai oui mais des
retards j'adore mais norbert évidemment
je vais rester
vous étiez bien ouais c'est très bien
lambert mais paraguay comme vous êtes
sur scène un one man chaud patate à la
nouvelle eve à paris je crois qu'il faut
vous y aviez tout de suite ce qu'on m'a
dit dans l'oreille babala moi j'ai pas
envie de vous mettre dans la bagarre
s'est rouvert
bravo mme lambert et on a bien recevoir
c'est bien aussi
hello bravo les verts est donc
aujourd'hui qu'on continue les quartiers
alors sergent belle complicité mardi
nous recevions franck gastambide pour
son film toute première fois et on peut
dire que ça a bien marché entre lui et
bernard montiel et voir bernard va lui
adresser la parole deux fois on va se
régaler
sans le désir qui montrent leur voyage
est rock de poufs la mission le fait me
lève à marcher son film tenir
c'est dur si j'aurais montrer soupire
c'est katia s'est donc perdre à l'étude
mais on aurait dû mettre des bulles
puisqu'ils me lui n'ose même pas lui
parler à la limite au fait de même c'est
le regard grèce alors sinon il ya un
dossier messieurs n'hésita pas non quoi
franchement c'est quoi encore l'histoire
ce que voulait qu'on attende c'est comme
vous voulez bon on fait le reste et vous
non vaut mieux le faire maintenant où le
veut ou jamais outre à la fois c'est
maintenant c'est dur c'est sûr qui c'est
sûr jean michel lefait resituer le
contexte récemment série la relance et
le tous pour un c'est ce jeu où les
chroniqueurs ou un gage qu'ils y perdent
et par contre s'ils gagnent ils ont un
gage le truc a aucun souci pour vous
expliquer car bien avant l'épreuve en
place devant nous des objets des
aliments mais nous on ne dit pas à quoi
ça va servir
donc pendant les pauses pub on se pose
des questions par exemple jean michel
quand vous lui présentez deux plaquettes
de beurre salé d'avoir une idée de
l'épreuve
gagner sa pitance est prêt à tout toi
pour passer à la télé un responsable
serait prêt à te mettre du beurre dans
le coup mais je pense pas que ça soit en
mairie avant cours de ce que je viens de
dire c'est sûr j'ai pas dans les faits
c'est parce que j'ai un morceau de
salades c'est quand même juste la vie
c'est quoi jean michel saive chasse
assez fort mais vous allez voir
alors est ce que je cherchais tu penses
allemand qui à 19h30 on va faire un jeu
comme ça sur la tnt le temps moi l'art
et du coup l'attention des mines d'or
voilà doute parce que vous l'avez dit
d'un seul coup compte que entré deux
plaquettes à la une feuille de salade
mais je comprends pourquoi ses plus
brillants à verser au canada
on fait un peu de consistance oxygène
torture
vous faites je voudrais te mettre le
beurre dans le cul avec la salade donc
une tortue viennent te lécher les arabes
c'est là qu'ils seraient tenus il ya qui
a voulu elle a montré cette séquence est
honteux c'est moi je voulais pas vous
êtes vraiment vous avez vraiment un
cerveau malade bien sûr ça n'a rien à
voir
voilà non moi je me désolidarise
associations de défense des tortues et
où courir et des salades allégé c'est
l'excusé pour excuser jean-michel on va
dire que les chroniqueurs ne sont pas
toujours dans leur état normal
et pour le prouver j'ai ralenti quelques
images de l'émission a tout de suite un
zapping de tous pas mon poste
la version bistrot
a ain vous c'est quoi vous vous aimez
très très très sportif
l'os avec les les délais d les
abdominaux ou pas je lui sers à ma peau
quand effectivement est pourquoi est-ce
que c'est lui qui sauva ou est ce qu'on
lui demande à votre avis peut-être on
envie de renouveler le cas c'est à
l'eysée belle douce il vous plaira
vous disiez exactement qui sont supposés
à la gerbe et mme émond 90 euros
nommait alors régnèrent l'exercice du
trou frondeur et c'est dur mais ça
prouve à voile à bernard et sa maison
est éliminé pour gilbert alors voix vous
avez pas déjà rêvé ce trailer jeu
toujours beaucoup les justes fruits
jean luc fabre
bonjour je m'appelle françoise j'aime
beaucoup de touche pas à mon poste je
trouve que c'est une très belle émission
mais j'aurais quand même un reproche
pourquoi julien courbet se fait il
remplaçait quatre fois par semaine par
l'autre con